[Music]
new lions quarterback jared goff says to
mike silver of nfl media i'm just
excited to be somewhere that i know
wants me
and appreciates me while they
appreciated you for a while in l.a jared
they gave up a bunch of stuff to trade
up to get you five years ago and then
they gave you that big contract just
something happened something caused to
go off the rails and i keep thinking of
that missed throw to brandon cooks in
super bowl
53 chris can't i can't quit thinking
about that because i'm telling you they
tried it in the first half we broke that
down it missed he didn't see him he
threw it underneath the robert woods
cooks was wide open they got a 25 minute
halftime they talked about it i'm sure
they plan to do it again they did it it
popped and goff didn't see it in time
that was the moment that i was like is
this guy really is he really top level
and maybe that was when the seat of
doubt was planted they still paid him
they still tried to work it out but they
ultimately came to the conclusion that
he had to go so the lions welcomed jared
goff to town
he's got some big shoes to fill in the
production that matthew stafford had and
you look around where's robert woods
where's cooper cup what do they really
have there they haven't signed kenny
galladay yet i don't know if they're
going to use the franchise tag or not
but the lions a lesser team with far
lesser accomplishments than the rams
obviously it's not going to be an easy
spot for golf yeah good news is you're
in a place where they want you bad news
is look around it's it's going to be
tough to have the kind of success you
had in l.a
well definitely i mean there's no doubt
about that when you look at their
football team i mean there's a lot of
question marks with the detroit lions
plus you don't know really what
direction they're going to go now with
all the new leadership you know what's
going to be there but you talk about oh
yeah there's a good tight end good
running back offensive lines okay right
they're obviously going to be a running
football team or at least based on that
i believe with dan campbell as your head
coach and anthony lin as your offensive
coordinator they're going to play that
style a game to where i don't think
they're going to be asking jared goff to
drop back 40 times a game and do all
that but we got the kenny gallaudet and
marvin jones you know their their their
uh contract situations i think they're
both free agents stan uh correct me if
i'm wrong right yes so
yeah there's a lot of things that need
to be juggled there there definitely is
but obviously brad holmes and dan
campbell signed off on trusting jared
goff and they're okay with playing you
know a style of football that they feel
like they can make work around his skill
set but i think it's gonna be
you know a year or two before we see
this team kind of turn the corner and
start to head in the right direction
you know and anthony lin the new
offensive coordinator had worked with
philip rivers for several years
with the chargers and i made the comment
during the break that goth kind of
reminds me of a stretched out phillip
rivers similar throwing motion right
similar mobility uh they just they're
gonna have their work cut out for him to
get the most out of golf and i could see
chris spielman who's now part of the
organization i don't really know what he
does and i don't think he really knows
what he does but i could see him trying
to trying to toughen jared goff up a
little bit you know we're going to
toughen you up you california boy we're
going to get you tough we're getting
ready to play in the cold oh and you
know that that narrative that you know
is a narrative because it it we saw it
happen although he did play better when
they went to green bay a couple of weeks
ago they're going to be at green bay
they're going to be at chicago they're
going to be at cleveland they're going
to be at pittsburgh this year so uh
depending upon when those games are
scheduled goff's going to have to have
to leave the friendly confines of that
dome and be ready to play in the
elements potentially and uh you know hey
this may be the kick in the butt he
needs maybe this is exactly
the developmental boost that's going to
cause him to just break out of whatever
maybe complacency set in once he got
paid we were speculating last week on
that possibility that one of the reasons
the rams were being so blunt and candid
in their criticism was he's got a little
complacent since he got paid well now
you get you get dumped by a team that
disrespects you openly before they do it
that's going to give you a chip on the
shoulder right if you never were that
guy that was going to show up and grab
someone by the shirt caller maybe you
are now and now i remember interviewing
jared goff when he was entering the
draft five years ago and i remember
thinking this guy's too nice you got you
can't you gotta have a little you don't
have to be a complete and total jerk
like me right but you gotta have a
little edge to you to be quarterback in
the nfl he had none now again that was
five years ago but i think that the
lions will find a way to instill that a
little bit and this trade i think will
cause him to bring a little bit more of
a willingness to be kind of a jerk kind
of a butthole to the table
well i mean it might it certainly can
toughen you up these type of things as
far as where you just become you know
a man as far as nfl terms are considered
just because yeah you were you thought
you were in a place where we had a good
relationship and things seemed well and
now you know i've been scarred because
the relationship wasn't what i thought
so he could be a different guy
altogether i doubt that though we've
seen none of that you know what what is
there to show us that there's any fire
there or that he's going to turn the
corner maybe dan campbell and anthony
lynn can get that out of him but i would
think that probably is part of the
frustration of the rams as well is that
attitude and mcveigh sometimes probably
going wait i'm not the quarterback why
doesn't why do i always gotta talk to
the offense to get everybody spruced up
and ready to go on a big drive of the
football game i think that's part of the
issue there so i'm extremely
extremely
interested to see how this goes
i don't really have a whole lot of doubt
that the matthew stafford mcvay thing is
going to be pretty good
the jared goff anthony lynn
detroit lions experiment i i got
questions i gotta see it i gotta see it
to believe it i'm just sorry the game
has been served on a silver platter for
jared goff for his whole career very
rarely has he had to hey wait the
offense isn't working guys i'll figure
it out i'll make big throws today
whatever it may be it's always been made
very easy to him and curtailed to his
talents and he was never asked to do
anything outside of his own comfort zone
and to me that's what i'm going to be
interested to see as well because he's
not going to get all these easy
completions we showed the stats from
earlier today nobody throws the ball
shorter you know nobody nobody in
football it's the air yards completions
they're all
right there at the line of scrimmage
consistently with him and it's just hard
to win that way this day and age and in
the nfl even when you have the best
defense and a good play caller and i
think that's going to be the thing i'm
going to be really
really interested to see how that plays
out
part of the reality for both teams in
this trade and any other transactions
like this that that are made over the
course of the next several weeks
the off-season program may be as
curtailed and or non-existent as it was
in 2020. there's been no indication that
normalcy is going to return for the nfl
when april rolls around with all the
guys showing up at the facility again
and the practices and all that and even
though they got full through a full
season
when they needed to practice and play
you don't need to do it
in the off-season and what did we hear
from the nfl pa all season long
we don't need this we don't need this
off sea we don't need it ever we
definitely don't need it in a pandemic
so goff may not get the on field
opportunities to get comfortable with
this new offense whatever they're going
to concoct for him and stafford may be
limited as well chris and that's just
something to keep in mind when you go
veteran for veterans or really anybody
draft a guy whatever you're going to be
doing it on the fly like we saw so many
teams have to do it in 2020. you know
one quick note on the rams that i forgot
to mention
they're bringing stafford in without any
type of a new contract he's under
contract for two more years 20 million i
love it 23 million next year i i i don't
i mean look yeah he doesn't want more
money but also from the rams perspective
what kind of security do you have for
everything you gave up they did the same
thing with jalen ramsey they brought him
in without security and it gives the guy
more leverage when it's time to talk so
yeah stafford's like hey i don't want a
new deal yeah i've got i've got all the
leverage i hold all the cards at some
point they're gonna have to pay me
because they gave up those first round
picks to get me
yeah i mean it could very easily be
you're right but i think the really the
point or the the point of it all and to
just like when you just listen when i
was just listening to you right and you
were saying that
i think they're going we don't care we
just wanted to get rid of jared goff and
we did and i think that's all they care
about and they're going to figure
everything else as they go but they're
happy with the guy they got and i think
for two years they'll go with him and
they'll figure out as they go and i
don't think matthew stafford is you know
gonna be the kind of guy to ask for more
money or do that right now he's made a
ton of money in his career and i think
he's going to just be very happy to be
in a new environment and feel
re-energized by that
this clearly doesn't help the lions now
they get a third round pick from the
rams in 2021 the first round picks start
next year i mean they get goffed but
goff as you'll say and you said right
out of the gates when we started the
show goff is a lesser quarterback than
stafford the lions have taken a step
back you know
and they're not going to come out and
say that they're not going to put that
on a banner hey team hey fans we're
committed to continue to stink at least
for one more year but that's the message
that's sent by this trade we've
sacrificed the guy who's been here 12
years who is a much better quarterback
than the one we've inherited we don't
get any first round picks for them until
next year they reportedly could have had
the eighth overall pick from the
carolina panthers plus more and they
said no thank you to that now they would
have had to find a quarterback otherwise
maybe they could have gotten teddy
bridgewater plus the the eighth overall
pick right throwing teddy they done
teddy and they get they're getting
stafford so what the hell i will we'll
give up teddy
yeah no i but my understanding and that
that one right there mike is that was a
team that was you know crossed off the
list by matthew stafford that that's my
understanding of the situation that was
one of the you i know you wrote on pro
football talk yesterday about the new
england patriots and that was unknown
that was tom curran tom curran's reprise
is it is it stafford initially said
anyone but the patriots okay i got you
sorry i didn't mean to misrepresent or
anything like that um but yeah i think
them and i've i've been told by a very
reliable source that yeah he kind of
squashed the carolina thing so i don't
think he wanted to happen he was trying
to steer this conversation into a team
where
he felt comfortable and and wanted to
play for and live there and i think
that's where the rams really you know
made a lot of sense for stafford
uh they look into that state income tax
in california before he made that
decision
you don't even have to look at that when
you already have what he's got in the
bank he's like what oh wait they have
taxes here who oh i got nine figures in
the bank big deal that guy has made well
over 200 million dollars since entering
the nfl in 2009 because he was one of
the last ones to get that jackpot first
overall draft pick before they took that
away in 2011.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports